when Lucasfilm finally announced the
title of Star Wars Episode nine the rise
of Skywalker fans wasted no time
speculating intensely about what it
could mean questions of who is rising
which Skywalker the title refers to and
whether one of the trilogy's main
characters would be confirmed as a
member of the Skywalker family swirled
through the Star Wars fandom fans won't
get the answers to their enquiries or
have their theories validated until
December 20th but Star Wars legend Mark
Hamill has already thrown in his two
cents Hamill whose character Luke
Skywalker seemingly died at the end of
the last Jedi took to Twitter to respond
to all the conjecture the actor
absolutely loves that fans are going
wild with their rise of Skywalker theses
and even offered up his own ideas about
who the titular Skywalker might be he
tweeted it's time for the 8 months of
speculation to begin is that Skywalker
kylo leia Anakin Luke a previously
unknown Skywalker is rheya Skywalker
hashtag cool title as soon as Hamill
pressed send on that tweet he
effectively opened up another floodgate
for fan theories to pore through
thousands of people responded to
Hamill's post sharing predictions about
how the film's events tie into the title
one fan theorized that the final battle
of the rise of Skywalker will be between
Rey and kylo Ren with some familiar
force ghosts jumping into the fray may
be Darth Vader Anakin Skywalker will
appear an aide Rey thus becoming the
Skywalker who rises according to theory
another fan responded to that idea with
a minor revision in a moment reminiscent
of Return of the Jedi the ghost of
Emperor Palpatine who is seemingly heard
cackling at the end of the rise of the
Skywalker trailer pops up behind kylo
while the ghost of Luke Skywalker
appears behind Rey during the duo's
battle one theory suggested that the
rise of Skywalker isn't about Anakin
Skywalker but about kylo Ren aka Ben
solo who has skywalker blood thanks to
his mother leia their response to
Hamill's tweet was it's about Ben's
Redemption Ben is the last Skywalker he
will rise from the dark and ask Rey out
kylo Ren couldn't drop his dark side
moniker returned to the light and
reassume his given name of Ben solo in
the rise of Skywalker that isn't too
wild of an idea
considering he is the only other known
Skywalker apart from the apparently
fallen Luke and his mother Leia he
wasn't always the first order leading
vadi who wanted to follow in his
grandfather Darth Vader's footsteps one
other popular theory about who the
nominal Skywalker
is that it isn't a single person at all
some fans believe that Skywalker will be
a new name for the Jedi and that Rey
will lead them to bring peace to the
galaxy Twitter user Dan Sandler
suggested that the Skywalker name might
be included in the ancient Jedi tax-rate
took from the mystical four Street just
before Yoda burned it down in the last
Jedi the books contain all that Rey
would need to teach a new generation of
Jedi but as Sandler speculates there may
not be Jedi anymore the Skywalker's
could be a combination of Jedi and Sith
this idea connects pretty seamlessly to
the title of the most recent Star Wars
film the last Jedi many assumed that the
title referred to Luke Skywalker and
perhaps Luke really is the last person
in the galaxy who will be known as a
Jedi with future force sensitive
individuals called Skywalker's for every
Star Wars fan there's a different theory
about the rise of Skywalker it would be
too great an undertaking to try to pick
apart every idea but director JJ Abrams
himself has revealed this about the new
film this movie is about the new
generation what they've inherited the
light and the dark and asked the
question about facing the greatest evil
are they ready check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Star Wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]